on recense 11 millions de personnes
aidantes en france elle assiste de façon
quotidienne un proche en perte
d'autonomie des situations difficiles
qui peuvent conduire l isolement pour
les soutenir l'institut une promotion de
la santé de saint quentin en yvelines
organisait son deuxième village entrée
dans ce village en fête a pour vocation
de faire découvrir des activités
ludiques de manière à proposer une pause
un peu dans le quotidien qui peut être
quelquefois un peu un peu lourd
ça permet aussi d'aller à la rencontre
de professionnels qui sont acteurs de
l'accompagnement du territoire ça permet
aussi de s'informer sur les aides
légales et aussi les aides extra légales
qui existent et sur lesquels ils peuvent
prendre appui parmi les stands le
comptoir des aidants pour informer
conseiller ces derniers il ya plein
d'associations sur le territoire de la
ville nouvelle de saint quentin qui
oeuvre pour aider à la fois les
personnes et leurs proches
donc ça permet vraiment de découvrir
toute la palette de associatif qui peut
y avoir vraiment pas aimables
un temps pour s'informer mais aussi un
temps pour soi
plusieurs ateliers étaient proposés pour
se détendre et passer un bon moment
je connais bien la maladie lissa aide
ça aide les deux moments de dépression
comme c'est pour ça que moi je me fais
aider par tous ces trucs telle une
rémunération pour le congé du projet
dans est en réflexion dans le projet de
loi de la sécurité sociale pour 2020
mais plus qu'un soutien financier cette
journée à l'entrée d'un village a rempli
son objectif de soutien moral les yeux
[Musique]